tell you one thing when the unsullied
make it to westeros they're gonna
annihilate wait wait dude it's gonna be
crazy slow down second of all i'm not up
to that yet oh i'm sorry oh yeah i
didn't know that i think i will erase it
i'm like you know what i'm saying i'm
like jordan right now but right now you
must listen to how this white dude is
talking to black people get out of my
face with your tommy behind my ass i'm
trying to make some beats yo i'm a day
jack
i put that [ __ ] on my chain wax huh
hey how's it going key and peel right
good so stoked you guys are here thanks
for coming out
you guys rock awesome
yo kevin let me get some red vines
wanna get out of here
[Music]
hey player how you doing man hey can i
make a request for sure man what are you
looking for hey man what could brother
walk with him oh school oh yeah all
right word okay what you looking for a
biggie tupac
biggie tupac
come on man that's too new
i'm talking about that old school man
you know what i'm talking about oh i
thought i did it was like a wu chang
clan
wu-tang clan come on man those fools
just came out hook a brother up with
some of that old school okay what uh i
don't know what you looking for man with
n-w-a
and
w-a
come on man what do i look like a kid
out there talking about the nwa four
shizzle my nitto criss cross applesauce
who's the boss tony dancer at a loss i
don't know it all right i'm talking
about that old school okay you know what
that's my bad old man all right we're
gonna take it back all right i'm gonna
bust out some run dmc for you right now
run dmv
[Music]
come on man i don't know about none of
this run dm theo wouldn't want to be a
automotive peer grab a donkey by the toe
give him gonorrhea i don't know it all
right all i know is some old school if
you can't give it to me you can't give
it to them come on man run dmc is old
school
what can you name a group you the dj man
i ain't trying to tell you how to do
your job that's the flash
man grand master flap you look you
sounding like a kid yourself talking
about grand master flash to the um bop
the bippity boppity boop that don't stop
the boogey to the bang bang boogie the
up chuck why people
talking about up chop sugar hill game
brother how we end up in candyland yo
what man
if you want some old school then you
come back here and find it yourself
i'm going on break
[Music]
get myself back here right here see
what's going on back here what we got
what we got let's see nope nope nope
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
ah
there now we talking
what the [ __ ] it's happening
[Music]
[Music]
if you cool like a pimp put your hands
up if you cool like a pit put your hands
off cause you're an actual pimp put your
hands up
if you own a bunch of women put your
hands up
[Music]
erection for 12 hours put your hands up
without the benefit of viagra put your
hands up
if you a real-life player put your hands
up if you abuse women's trust put your
hands up if you treat her like objects
put your hands up
[Music]
if you will real-life gangster put your
hands up if you a real-life gangster put
your hands up if you kill other people
put your hands up
if you're the biggest boss here put your
hands up
if you run an actual drug ring put your
hands up
if you just realize that you're full of
[ __ ] put your hands up
the joint blocks in the morning
yo joey blunts
[Applause]
y'all
look man i grew up in the hood all right
so no
so he would want to but he can't do it
because of that
[Applause]
we'll be right back
101.3
[Applause]
[Music]
well tonight we gonna party till the
party don't stop and the party don't
stop because it keeps on going non-stop
going to party all night gonna keep this
party going cause the party won't stop
it's been two straight days and the
party's still going two three four five
six seven days till it's friday again
and the party keeps going party all
night cause it's at an all night party
friday night nine p.m hop in the car
call my friends drinks in the back girls
run going to a party sending texts cell
phone rings ipad facebook party time
skin tight jeans friday nights dance
dance dance cause tonight we're going
out and we ain't coming back cause the
party won't stop and we'll go all night
friday night every night the party's
going down down down down down no no no
no new york city lake chicago houston
lilly san diego phoenix austin fort
worth memphis denver portland vegas
[Music]
[Music]
friday night every night the party's
going down down down down down
[Music]
new york city l.a chicago houston philly
san diego phoenix austin fort worth
boxing memphis denver portland vegas
tucson fresno akron tampa pittsburgh
newer plano lincoln loving durham salem
dating city city city city city
never gonna keep it going
then we'll just keep partying
[Music]
party party party
[Music]
so tonight we're gonna party till the
party don't stop so i have finished the
kitchen i finished my bedroom i finished
the office and i'm just wrapping up the
living room okay so here i'll get pack a
lacking i love it i love it uh mind if i
put on some music i do not i do not
i got this new dubstep
uh
what is i don't know what that is
oh dude you're gonna love it oh cool
cool man
[Music]
i like this
wait for the drop i'm sorry the drop
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what is
that the music
i'm sorry is that music oh yeah dude
that's the dubstep man that's my jam
well it's it's a little uh loud and
disorienting and you know you're being a
little rough with my things ruffled dude
your stuff is fine why am i sweating so
much because you're feeling it is that a
good thing yes
come on man just give it another shot
okay
okay i will
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
dude you're totally jacking my flow up
dude your nose is bleeding and so is
mine
awesome it doesn't really seem like
music to me
okay wow wally getting a little bit old
no all right do that come on no didn't
realize that okay um yeah what would you
rather listen to i can hook you up with
some hootie on the blowfish if that's
your oh that's funny is that good color
me bad you know what
go ahead i don't care i see what you're
doing go ahead and play it i don't care
because i'm not that old i can get into
it okay we just let's just get this
stuff packed play it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]